it is the first time of course the
family has spent the festive period at
their Norfolk estate since 2019. here
they're seen walking into church
together
you can see the king and queen consort
leading the way there as the others move
behind
and later when they came out the Prince
of Wales could be seen chatting with
members of the public who turned out to
greet the roll family and accepting
Bunches of flowers from well wishers
well Sky's Royal correspondent Laura
bundock has the very latest from
Sandringham
the Royal party as they made their way
out of their church back towards
Sandringham house for their traditional
Christmas lunch stopped to say hello and
thank you to the well-wishers who'd been
gathered here for many hours this
morning the king and queen consort and
perhaps the ones they all really wanted
to see the Wales is the prince and
princess of Wales with their three
children Prince Louis included making
his first appearance here for a
Sandringham Christmas and certainly
speaking to people as they make their
way out of the church they are very
happy with what they've seen they're
pleased to have seen the king a lot of
them telling me they wanted to support
him for what is a huge moment in many
ways another Milestone as he leads his
family for the first time here at
Christmas of course lots of thoughts to
to the queen and that is a theme
certainly we're expecting to appear in
his first Christmas message it was
recorded at St George's Chapel in
Windsor very close to the final resting
place of the lake queen and the King
will no doubt want to pay tribute to his
mother in that speech but certainly this
sense that things carry on things go on
and of the royal family here today A
sense of that as well interesting to see
Prince Andrew here of course he's not
been seen in public at all since he had
was stripped of all his Royal roles
he was here today at the earlier service
and then here later on as well I spoke
to one person in the crowd who'd
actually met him and said that he seemed
very cheerful he was happy to be here
perhaps not the biggest crowd pleaser
when you compare him to the likes of The
Prince and Princess of Wales but Andrew
here his daughters were here as well and
of course we await the king's message a
little later on this afternoon